[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24 le
bras de fer entre le gouvernement
français et les grévistes dans le
secteur pétrolier c'est durci et
Isabelle borne a lancé la réquisition du
personnel pour faire fonctionner les
dépôts de carburant des sauts l'impact
d'un conflit social est devenu
insupportable pour de trop nombreux
Français à lancer Olivier Véran les
réquisitions sont effectives au dépôt de
port Jérôme en Seine-Maritime les
Français devraient voir une amélioration
très sensible dans les prochains jours
des réserves de carburant dans les
stations services selon le porte-parole
du gouvernement la cgtfo dénonce une
attaque inadmissible contre le droit de
grève les raffineries de Total énergie
et des sauts sont tout en grève mais
chez Total énergie les négociations sont
ouvertes depuis cet après-midi avec les
grévistes un tiers des stations services
en France manquent toujours de carburant
les files d'attentes dans les stations
services du coup continuent de
s'allonger et les automobilistes sont
toujours en colère alors comment larmes
de réquisition fonctionne-t-elle quel
impact sur les Français à court
d'essence pourquoi les négociations
bloquentaient
les conséquences politiques de ce
conflit social il va poser la question à
mes invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir mes
côtés à Thomas apporte bonsoir vous êtes
député de la nuque 3e circonscription de
Seine-Saint-Denis et d'ailleurs vous
étiez sur le site dont on va parler dans
un petit instant bienvenue à vous en
face de vous Jenny kalimy bonsoir Janick
rédactrice en chef adjoint au service
politique
allez-y éditorialise politique
éditorialise politique toujours donc au
service politique du Parisien
donc ancienne du Parisien et on est ravi
de vous avoir Janique bonsoir à vous
bonsoir nous avons également avec nous
Michel ruimi bonsoir économiste et
professeur à Sciences Po ça n'a pas
changé là jusque là jusque là
est avec nous
vers droit de Neuilly-sur-Marne bonsoir
initiateur du collectif Stop racket
énergie et vous vous appelez justement
contre les prix délirants de l'énergie
merci d'être avec nous alors je le
disais un tiers des stations services en
France il faut le savoir quand même pour
notre public international manque
toujours de carburant les files
d'attente dans les stations-service bien
sûr continuent les automobilistes sont
toujours en colère on va écouter des
réactions
c'est la galère c'est la catastrophe
parce que ça fait 3 heures de cours
derrière mais on a fait le tour de pompe
d'essence il y en a pas même sur les
applications ils nous disent c'est là
bien sûr ça marche mais jusqu'à quand je
sais pas périclition s'il faut en
arriver là oui oui je pense quand on
voit les queues quand on voit le blocage
du pays à cause de d'une centaine de
personnes qui ont en plus des
revendications qui étaient pris en
compte en novembre alors pourquoi faire
ça tout de suite
voilà pour paralyser le pays
le gouvernement français donc je vous le
disais a décidé de réquisitionner au
dépôt de port Jérôme en Seine-Maritime
la cgtfo dénonce une attaque
inadmissible je cite contre le droit de
grève on va écouter Olivier Vérand le
porte-parole du gouvernement
l'impact de ce conflit social est devenu
nous en avons conscience insupportable
pour de trop nombreux Français certains
sont empêchés d'aller travailler
d'amener leurs enfants à l'école de
faire leurs courses parfois de se
soigner on va retrouver justement au
dépôt de so à Port Jérôme notre envoyé
spécial tarikai Tarek bonsoir les
réquisitions ont démarré sur le site
tout à fait une des premières
acquisitions ont été mises en oeuvre ici
au niveau de cette raffinerie de
Gravenchon en scène maritime c'est ce
qui a été confirmé par un responsable
syndical qui affirme que un des salariés
travaillant pour Esso la raffinerie donc
à Gravenchon a reçu une lettre qui lui a
été remise par un huissier de justice
lui demandant de reprendre le travail ce
salarié est responsable donc du
déplacement des hydrocarbures et de
l'ouverture des Vans selon les
responsables syndicaux le salarié en
question se conformera à la lettre et
reprendra le travail puisqu'il n'est pas
question ici de faire quarrière aux
salariés le risque de se faire licencier
la CGT s'est exprimée au sujet de ces
réquisitions la firme que c'est un c'est
une atteinte au droit de grève et elle
compte
donc faire un référé dès demain matin
déposer un référé dès demain matin le
secrétaire général de la CGT Philippe
Martinez vient de s'exprimer ici même
devant la raffinerie à Philippe Martinez
considère que c'est réquisitions sont
scandaleuses il fait un parallèle
justement avec ceux qui s'est passé en
2010 lors de la réforme des retraites où
il affirme que le président Sarkozy et
la France ont été condamnés par l'oité
l'Organisation internationale du travail
pour lui ce qui était valable en 2010
reste valable aujourd'hui merci Tarek
donc en direct de ce site à Esso ou la
réquisition a démarré Michel rugby
puisque vous êtes l'économiste du débat
vous allez nous le cadrer ce débat elle
nous explique grosso modo ce qui se
passe tout de même chez Total et Esso
parce que il ne se passe pas exactement
la même chose il y a eu un accord qui
avait été signé chez Esso là nous étions
dans un site Esso et puis il y a total
total ou manifestement la négociation
ont démarré aujourd'hui avec les
grévistes donc quels sont les
revendications pour faire simple et
est-ce qu'il y a négociation en ce
moment alors l'idée et je vais essayer
d'être le plus court et le plus bref et
en même plus clair dans la mesure où en
fait d'une certaine manière il y a des
négociations salariales qui sont
ouvertes chaque année simplement le fait
c'est que les les grévistes de Total
face aux on va dire aux dividendes
distribués aux actionnaires c'est un
réflexe on va dire naturel entre
guillemets considère qu'ils n'ont pas
une juste rémunération et donc demande à
être revalorisée
et du coup
c'est ça oui oui au-delà c'est le fait
de la revalorisation après ça dépend du
pourcentage après ça se négocie après
l'idée c'est aujourd'hui les total n'a
pas engagé des négociations et donc il y
a une un blocage notamment de de
séraffineries donc voilà donc total a
fait un premier geste semble-t-il
aujourd'hui puisqu'elle a ouvert donc
des négociations avec les grévistes
c'était ça un petit peu la nouveauté
après il faut les terminer Thomas porte
vous vous étiez vous êtes allé justement
sur le site en Seine-et-Marne pourquoi
soutenez-vous les grévistes donc je
rappelle que pour Esso il s'agit de la
CGT et de FO ce sont eux qui sont en
grève exactement et au delà il y a des
salariés qui sont aujourd'hui en grève
et qui sont pas syndiqués ni à iPhone et
à la CGT il y a une colère sociale parce
que ça vient d'être dit il y a des
entreprises qui ont fait des bénéfices
records parce qu'on parle de vaisseau
mais c'est avec son mobile c'est 19
milliards sur trois mois total c'est 19
milliards sur 6 mois et on parle
d'augmentation annuelle mais les
salariés ils ont ils voient leurs
patrons qui sont augmentés de 52% le PDG
de Total c'est augmenter de 52%. et les
salariés ils demandent 10% d'angletation
de salaire ce qui représente ces
chiffres et 151 millions d'euros pour
l'entreprise totale qui vient de verser
2,6 milliards de dividendes
supplémentaires en avance aux
actionnaires donc la mobilisation moi je
le dis c'est une question de justice
sociale est-ce que des salariés
aujourd'hui qui produisent la richesse
doivent en toucher une partie doivent
avoir des juste rémunération parce que
j'ai entendu des salaires 5000 euros ce
sont des mensonges absolus de la
direction totale venez sur les piquets
de grève les gens sont en 250 3000 euros
alors ça dépendra du net ou du brute
du carburant toute la journée qui sont
compliqués c'est des salariés qui
travaillent en 3/8 avec des conditions
de travail qui sont pas simples donc
arrêtons de stigmatiser celles et ceux
qui aujourd'hui se mobilisent
justement on voit tout de même que ça
bloque l'ensemble du pays on a vu ses
automobilistes qui font la queue est-ce
que Thomas porte a raison et est-ce que
le gouvernement a raison de
réquisitionner aujourd'hui je pense que
effectivement quand on voit les scènes
incroyables dans toute la France se
produire comme si on n'avait pas
d'énergie il fallait réquisitionner on a
l'énergie qui est un bien commun il faut
quand même se dire qu'il ne faut pas
réserver le même traitement pour
l'énergie que pour d'autres choses il ne
faut pas réserver un traitement
ordinaire à l'énergie donc il est il est
inadmissible et indispensable de de
débloquer le pays et de ne pas laisser
les Français dans la paralysie mais ce
que je tiens à dire c'est que il y a
deux responsables dans cette histoire le
gouvernement et les grandes entreprises
les grandes entreprises qui font
d'énormes profits qui mettent les
Français à genoux qui mettent les
collectivités à genoux en multipliant
par 10 20 30 le prix de l'énergie qui
met les entreprises à genoux également
le boulanger si vous allez le voir s'il
devait répercuter le prix de l'énergie
sur sa baguette la baguette elle
coûterait 2 euros 65 et le gouvernement
également qui a mis en place un bouclier
tarifaire le bouclier tarifaire qui
est-ce qui le paye ce sont les Français
le gouvernement refuse d'être taxer les
super profits et en parallèle vous avez
d'autres personnes de la majorité comme
Édouard Philippe qui jettent de l'huile
sur le feu en disant qu'il faudrait
aller faire une réforme de la retraite
en passant la retraite à 67 ans donc
voilà les deux responsables par contre
le gouvernement prend un risque
aujourd'hui lorsqu'il décide de
réquisitionner
alors d'abord on ne prend pas de risques
juridique parce que contrairement à ce
que dit Philippe Martinez l'OIT
l'Organisation internationale du travail
n'a pas condamné le gouvernement à
l'époque de de Monsieur Sarkozy et
Monsieur Fillon parce que cette mesure
aurait été illégale anticonstitutionnel
non c'est pas ce qu'il y avait eu à
l'époque au contraire elle avait
salué l'efficacité de la mesure avait en
revanche souligné l'absence de
concertation du gouvernement de l'époque
là donc c'est différent l'OIT n'avait
pas condamné premièrement et
deuxièmement si le droit de grève je
reviens à la France stricto-sensuit est
un effectivement un droit
constitutionnel le droit de réquisition
dans certaines conditions est formelle
et de proportionnalité par rapport au
risque que très encadré c'est très
encadré et puis donc sont les préfets
qui doivent prendre on l'a vu cette
décision et évidemment ces sujets à des
recours donc d'un point de vue juridique
le gouvernement ne prend pas de risque
en revanche apprend deux autres risques
le risque de dresser et de braquer des
grévistes ou des salariés même qui sont
et des syndicalistes qui eux aussi ne
sont pas indemmes notamment la CGT de
motivation strictement politique on y
reviendra mais en revanche tout de même
il risque de les braquer encore plus on
verra ce qu'il en a de viendra dans les
prochains jours et troisièmement
pardonnez-moi je termine là-dessus les
réquisitions et le gouvernement le dit
dans la coulisse ne sont pas la solution
c'est une petite solution d'attente qui
permet de montrer que le gouvernement
intervient on va dire enfin et que
certains verrous vont pouvoir être vont
pouvoir sauter mais le gouvernement le
dit lui-même ce n'est certainement pas
la panacée et il faut le gouvernement le
dit et je ne dédouane pas la
responsabilité du gouvernement dans tout
ce qui se passe mais c'est une autre
question le gouvernement le dit lui-même
l'issue c'est la discussion et la
négociation Michel rummy est-ce que ça
peut justement débloquer
les stations services débloquées en tout
cas le dépôt de carburant et donc
réalimenter son service cette
réquisition les réquisitions sont de
court terme et c'est pour un déstockage
après les raffineries on remet pas en
cause le droit de grève c'est ça qui
pose la difficulté le problème et c'est
une solution de court terme les Français
ont besoin pour diverses raisons je peux
pas rentrer sur les aspects métiers
essentiels ou quoi que ce soit ont
besoin de certains carburants la
difficulté et qu'il convient et c'est là
qui se pose
mais en illustration le dialogue social
qui ne se fait pas et notamment en même
temps masking chaîne quelque part c'est
le fait que quelque part au-delà de cet
aspect de Total etc c'est que le
gouvernement dans une certaine mesure
n'entend pas éventuellement la grande
montée progressivement et pour l'instant
ça tire ce problème là ça risque d'avoir
ça risque d'avoir que au-delà si on
n'arrive pas à trouver une solution
rapidement donc ça veut dire négociation
sur un résultat ce qui débouche un
résultat et surtout ce qu'il faut bien
voir aussi c'est que même si on arrive à
un résultat la remise en ordre on va
dire du stock des des pardon des
stations services etc ça va continuer
là-dessus et ça se met pas tout de suite
du jour au lendemain ça prend du temps
donc ça va aussi continuer c'est plus
longtemps à trouver une solution plus on
va tarder et aujourd'hui à la limite à
supposer qu'on trouve un accord dans les
jours qui viennent à mon sens on
reviendra à une situation normale début
novembre donc c'est ce qui pose ce type
de problème et donc à supposer que ça ça
retarde associé à d'autres grandes qui
peuvent arriver ça risque de faire tâche
l'huile d'autant plus dans une
perspective du 16 octobre vous pensez
que ça risque de faire tâche d'huile on
va écouter Sandrine Rousseau justement
et vous allez réagir c'est sur France
Inter
France Info
moi j'espère que ce sera l'étincelle qui
déclenchera un mouvement de grève
générale parce que là la colère dans le
pays est-elle que je pense qu'il y a
vraiment matière à faire à bloquer et à
changer les politiques libérales qui
sont qui sont mises en place par le
gouvernement elle appelle la grève
générale donc un mouvement social de
grande ampleur Thomas porte vous êtes
dans cette veine nous on regarde ce qui
se passe dans le pays on prend la
température et la colère elle est pas
que chez les que chez les salariés des
raffineries il y a pas aujourd'hui un
secteur d'activité qui n'est pas
concerné par des grèves vous prenez
l'agroalimentaire vous prenez compris le
secteur des transports on a les
cheminots qui seront en grève le 18
octobre on a les profs du secteur de la
formation professionnelle et qui vont se
mobiliser la semaine prochaine il y a
une colère dans le pays et vous avez
payé une marche organisée
veulent un autre projet de société qui
veulent un partage des richesses à venir
dimanche prochain marché avec nous à 14h
au départ à la place de la Nation mais
vous avez pas de la réquisition l'effet
que ça c'est que par exemple la
raffinerie de Donges qui n'était plus en
grève s'est mis en grève ce matin à 80%
suite aux annonces du gouvernement parce
que c'est une remise en cause claire du
droit de grève de faire ça et
aujourd'hui le gouvernement on a vu que
c'était légal je termine sur une chose
le gouvernement il fait le choix de la
matraque et de la violence pour protéger
les super profits de quelques-uns parce
que c'est ça aujourd'hui vous allez
montrer des réactions automobilistes moi
je suis allé en voiture voir les
salariés donc j'ai fait aussi le plein
de ma voiture j'ai discuté avec les gens
sur des stations il y a aussi des gens
qui pointent du doigt la direction
totale qui dit comment ça se fait que le
patron s'augmente de 52 % qu'on gavent
les actionnaires de 8 milliards et que
les salariés ils touchent pas leur du
donc il y a une question du partage de
richesse dans ce pays qui est posée et
c'est ça l'arrêt là il la pose au coeur
du débat politique et le gouvernement
qui irresponsable qui ne veut pas taxer
les super profils porte une lourde
responsabilité dans le conflit
aujourd'hui monsieur bactéries avoir une
grève générale est-ce que vous adhérez à
ce que vient de dire justement mon
voisin
général par contre je dis une chose
c'est qu'effectivement je partage le
constat on est sur un terreau qui est
explosif on demande des efforts
financiers considérables aux Français le
le prix du caddie a explosé tous les
prix ont explosé sauf que les salaires
n'ont pas été revalorisés à la hauteur
on demande des efforts drastiques aux
Français dans leur vie quotidienne quand
on vous dit que vos enfants dans vos
écoles vont être dans des classes à 19
degrés que dans les Gildas ça va être 14
degrés que il y aura plus d'éclairage
public et que derrière il y a pas on ne
voit pas de partage de l'effort par les
énergéticiens qui eux pour le coup sans
mettre plein les poches vous dites ça
mais vous savez qu'il y a un accord au
niveau européen d'ailleurs on a parlé
qui va permettre de financer en
l'occurrence le bouclier et tarifaire
français indispensable de le faire et de
le faire rapidement aujourd'hui on dit
aux Français chauffez-vous moins et
payer plus bah forcément ça crée de la
colère donc de manière générale il faut
un partage des efforts par tout le monde
et effectivement on est sur un terreau
qui est explosif et dans tous les
secteurs donc effectivement je pense
encore une fois qu'on est sur un terreau
qui est pire que celui des gilets jaunes
parce qu'il n'y a plus de barrage est-ce
que c'est ça le risque effectivement une
sorte de voilà une sorte de mouvement
gilet jaune nouveau mouvement écoutez
personne ne le sait effectivement il y a
cette grande manifestation le 18 octobre
le 16
effectivement il y a de nouvelles
raffineries qui sont touchées par le
mouvement de grève et peut-être aussi
pire j'allais dire excusez-moi c'est
chez EDF
donc les centrales nucléaires qui déjà
étaient mal en point et qui risque elle
aussi de ne pas fournir l'électricité
dont on aurait besoin maintenant est-ce
qu'il y a un risque oui il y a un risque
bien sûr qu'il y a un risque mais
personne ne peut dire de façon assurée
qu'il risque d'avoir et un mouvement
social et un mouvement syndical un
mouvement politique et un mouvement des
gilets jaunes en revanche il est temps
de le désamorcer et se désamorçage il
est temps qu'il arrive parce que c'est
très intéressant votre introduction tout
à l'heure vous avez dit deux fois c'est
pas du tout une critique un bras de fer
entre nos escients un bras de fer entre
le gouvernement et les grévistes vous
avez oublié entre les entreprises les
directions des entreprises là on peut
dire que le gouvernement fait pression
sur ces entreprises non moi je trouve
pas justement je trouve que depuis que
le mouvement existe il y a un mouvement
de grève depuis le 27
il y a eu le climat politique dont on a
parlé cet été avec une montée il y avait
pas encore les grèves dont on parle mais
il y avait le pouvoir la crainte du
pouvoir d'achat les deux lois sur le
pouvoir d'achat qui était discutés on
savait qu'il y avait un malaise y
compris au sein des troupes premiers
sens donc une certaine partie donc de la
majorité demandez la taxation des super
profits pour les énergéticiens café le
gouvernement café l'exécutif au sens
large pas grand chose si ce n'est appelé
effectivement à la négociation mais le
rôle du gouvernement d'un strict point
de vue d'intérêt national et d'intérêt
politique au sens limité du terme pour
que ça ne lui revienne pas à la figure
comme un boomerang c'est de pousser
notamment les entreprises qui
effectivement ont fait des milliards dû
à la rente et non pas l'investissement
et au risque de négocier pourquoi est-ce
que Total et pourquoi est-ce que le
gouvernement n'a pas poussé total qui
effectivement était prêt à négocier
commencer ne serait-ce que d'un mois
d'ouvrir les négociations déjà la
semaine dernière Macron est trop tardive
à votre avis alors il n'est jamais trop
tard pour bien faire il s'agit de voir
ce qu'il va dire ce soir mais
effectivement il est temps qu'il parle
il est temps qu'il désamorce parce que
je termine là-dessus si il y a un risque
de gilet gilet jauneisation crise
sociale ce n'est pas sûr monsieur porte
ce n'est pas sûr du tout que ce soit la
gauche en termes politiques qui en
récolte les gains quand il y a ce genre
de manifestation une France à l'arrêt et
peut-être du désordre dans la rue
l'histoire et la comparaison
géographique avec d'autres pays très
proches européens montre que c'est
plutôt l'extrême droite qui en profite
donc personne personne n'a intérêt à ce
que les choses s'envenimes et les
responsabilités sont parfaitement
partagées entre une CGT qui fait tout de
même d'assurance chair même si
fondamentalement il faut une négociation
des salaires une entreprise ou des
directions d'entreprises qui n'ont pas
voulu négocier ou trop tard et des grand
public qui n'ont eux n'ont plus n'ont
pas assez fait pression sur les
directions d'entreprises alors comme
vous parliez de taxation des entreprises
on va écouter Bruno Le Maire sur ce
sujet qui lui parle de vente
la réalité c'est que c'est les rentes
auxquelles nous voulons nous attaquer
moi je ne veux pas qu'il y ait des
énergéticiens qui s'appelle EDF total ou
engie qui puisse profiter de la
situation vendre à prix d'or de
l'électricité sans qu'à un moment donné
l'état de leur disent écoutez là vous
prenez trop on reprend cette rente qui
est excessive et on la redistribué à nos
compatriotes et aux entreprises pour
vous protéger nous le faisons depuis un
an
parce qu'il y a effectivement cette
contribution européenne qui a été mise
en place qui en fait l'idée c'est en
fait d'avoir un seuil de prix et le
gouvernement enfin les gouvernements les
états récupère donc le différentiel
entre le prix de vente et le prix
affiché par le gouvernement donc c'est
une façon de financer le bouclier
tarifaire parce que expliquez-nous
demande bien le gouvernement demande
bien aux énergéticiens de contribuer
financière quand on dit taxer des super
profits il y a deux termes qui convient
absolument de de là
je reviens sur les génératriciens
c'est-à-dire notamment taxer il y a un
problème de c'est le terme taxé en fait
les entreprises sont déjà taxées sur
l'impôt société là on leur demande une
autre taxe donc au plan constitutionnels
on peut pas être taxé une deuxième fois
au motif que donc c'est pas le terme qui
convient deuxième chose c'est super
profit qu'on vient de le déterminer
là-dessus et donc là on dit voilà c'est
tout ce qui est au-dessus de 80 euros on
vous prend d'une certaine manière 26
milliards d'euros a priori qui seraient
récupérés par l'état français et là on
pourra dire oui c'est une contribution
de cette nature et c'est là où il
convient de voir c'est que les
entreprises on peut pas les taxer mais
leur incité à faire d'une part on a
incité totale à faire son rabais mais
également aussi de dire bien je
considère que ce surplus on va dire
au-delà de 180 euros et on va dire un
niveau qui est quand même qui vous
permet d'une part de faire fonctionner
votre entreprise de faire éventuellement
certaines investissements pour le futur
mais au-delà il me semble que ça soit
légitime on va dire de pouvoir les taxer
pour pouvoir faire bénéficier la
communauté nationale donc taxer
l'ensemble du secteur c'est ce que vous
souhaitez à la nuque c'est en fait ça
c'est une taxation pas seulement des
énergéticiens mais de l'ensemble des
entreprises qui ont fait des sociétés
maritimes les trois qui n'ont rien
inventé pendant cette crise là mais qui
en profitait du marché qui ont spéculé
pour accumuler des richesses mais quand
j'entends Bruno Le Maire déjà il a les
éléments de langage c'est dire on va le
faire donc c'est déjà ils sont pas dans
l'action donc ils le font pas et
véritablement il faut les mettre à
contribution c'est grand groupe enfin je
veux dire il y a quand même un sujet on
le dit depuis le début sur ce plateau
c'est un constaté partagé quand vous
versez 8 milliards d'euros à des
actionnaires que vous avancez de 2,6
milliards d'euros en plus cette année
une avance sur dividende et que vous
refusez augmenter les salaires parce que
on a parlé de de négociation tardive ça
fait 6 mois que les organisations
syndicales de Total demande des
ouvertures d'augmenter les salaires
pour couvrir l'inflation et qui est
aussi en lien avec les dividendes qui a
été versé on parle l'an dernier si vous
prenez les chiffres des salaires qui ont
été là me semble-t-il
je pense que c'est pour ça je pense que
ce qui se passe en ce moment c'est
devenu autre chose qu'une simple
négociation de salaire on voit bien
depuis la crise
ukrainienne depuis la crise du pouvoir
d'achat qu'on est en train de se
transformer enfin surtout depuis la
guerre ukrainienne pardonnez-moi
est une crise politique au sens très
large du terme lorsque le président de
la République lui-même parlait du 14 le
14 juillet lors de son allocution ils
sont son interview à la télévision de
profiteurs de guerre on est dans une
situation pour parler des énergéticiens
et effectivement de ces profits qui sont
nés de la rente et non pas de la prise
de risque et de l'investissement on voit
bien qu'on est dans une situation
extrêmement exceptionnelle alors
peut-être ne faut-il pas parler de
taxation et d'impôts c'est quelque chose
de pérenne et qu'il faut parler de d'une
taxation effectivement limitée à un
certain nombre d'entreprises est
limitées dans le temps mais sans parler
de 5 de 10 de 20%. il fallait de toute
façon qui est il y avait cette prise de
conscience qu'il y avait un problème de
pouvoir d'achat en France c'était tout
le monde le reconnaissait il a manqué je
trouve la bonne volonté ou le réalisme
politique j'allais dire de la direction
de de politique au sens large du terme
de la direction de total il a manqué
l'IMP situation politique de l'exécutif
et ça s'est greffé encore une fois à une
surenchère de la part de la CGT à
laquelle se joint maintenant Force
Ouvrière pour des raisons notamment bien
sûr de de
leadership d'une mobilisation sociale et
puis d'un congrès qui aura lieu en mars
où on sait que il y a des courants plus
ou moins radicaux qui vont s'affronter
au sein de la CGT mais on voit bien que
ce n'est pas une simple négociation
salariale en tant que telle qui
apportera la solution politique en tout
cas effectivement très important art of
bactéries ce qu'il faudrait une
négociation générale des salaires
finalement en France je pense qu'il faut
justement c'est le moment de d'aller sur
un autre débat et c'est le fait de
remettre la participation des salariés
dans le capital des entreprises sur la
table et il faut une vraie prise en main
par les salariés une vraie association
parce que le salarié il est responsable
quand l'entreprise est dans la
difficulté le salariés et quand il y a
eu des référendums locaux parfois les
syndicats aller sur une direction par
exemple le Smart en 2015 on demande aux
salariés ce que vous êtes d'accord pour
travailler 39 heures payer 37 les
syndications opposent 90% des salariés
disent oui pour sauver l'entreprise
parce qu'en fait on leur donne la
possibilité d'être associé moi ce que je
demande c'est d'être enfin d'associer
véritablement les salariés à la à la
gestion de l'entreprise en tout cas dans
le capitaine
la participation c'est pas l'association
à la gestion attention c'est la
participation aux bénéfices je demande à
ce que les salariés en assemblée
générale puissent déterminer par exemple
le salaire du PDG du groupe Total sauf
qu'aujourd'hui ça n'est pas le cas parce
que les salariés n'ont pas cette
possibilité là j'en termine fortement
avec
ça c'est pas un principe marxiste c'est
un principe simplement gaulliste on va
écouter enfin on va regarder justement
ce reportage qui a été fait sur un
marché en France parce qu'on va voir que
l'impact justement de ces 15 jours de
grève et bien l'impact est très
important auprès de nombreux français
non seulement ceux qui se rendent au
travail le matin mais également sur
l'ensemble de l'économie française on va
regarder
les étales sont encore bien achalandées
mais le manque de carburant inquiète
cette maraîchère Marielle Marc Rossini a
déjà revu son activité à la baisse
demain par exemple il n'y a aucune
livraison on restera sur le marché mais
on pourra pas faire nos livraisons
justement pour essayer d'économiser le
bus de carburant possible même constat
au Halles d'Avignon ce maraîcher vend
exclusivement des produits locaux le
manque de carburant l'oblige à proposer
des fruits et légumes moins frais
on va trois fois par semaine au
Saint-Etienne du grès là on est obligé
de le réduire à une fois par semaine
donc ce qui déjà nous complique parce
que nous on dans des produits frais
la chaîne de fonctionnement est impactée
ce matin les clients ont déserté les
allées quant au commerçants ils ont déjà
répercuté leurs difficultés
d'approvisionnement sur les prix
peut pas forcément avoir toute la
marchandise qu'on veut la marchandise
augmente aussi parce qu'il faut vous
dire que c'est répercuté sur le prix de
la marchandise et en plus les gens donc
qui donc un petit phénomène de panique
ne se rendent plus aussi facilement dans
les halles que ce qu'il le faisait la
pénurie d'essence réduit les stocks
disponibles et en conséquence les prix
augmentent pour le consommateur
sur l'économie c'est pas seulement
effectivement les Français qui seront au
travail le matin mais également sur les
marchés ce blocage depuis 15 jours à un
impact d'ailleurs doux la justification
de l'utilisation de l'ordre public pour
utiliser je connais les vieilles
ficelles pour utiliser un discrédit sur
une grève et monter l'opinion publique
entre les salariés en lutte il y a
aujourd'hui un responsable du blocage je
tiens à le dire ici c'était le patron de
Total mobile moi j'appelle Emmanuel
Macron à réquisitionner ces deux patrons
alors mais allez mettre dans une salle
et leur dire maintenant vous allez
atteindre des négociations et vous
négociez avec les salariés mais bien sûr
Emmanuel Macron s'il a envie de prendre
son téléphone et d'appeler les deux PDG
il les appelle pour les mettre autour de
la table donc il a une responsabilité
aujourd'hui il fait le choix du rapport
de force moi j'espère qu'il va
réquisitionner les patrons et leur dire
ça suffit maintenant on a des salariés
qui sont mobilisés depuis 22 jours des
gens qui perdent de l'argent qui
demandaient salaire que l'entreprise
c'est gavée avec des dividendes il est
temps de revenir à la raison et de
négocier avec ces gens-là c'est ça la
solution est-ce qu'il faudrait une
négociation globale des salaires en
France
il y a plus de il y a pas de politique
nationale de revenus à part le sur le
SMIC ok donc ça reste ça reste sur du
ressort des entreprises
l'idée de voir après donc on l'état la
problématique et qui est là c'est que
Total Excel sont des entreprises privées
donc l'étape inciter c'est toujours et
non pas exigé donc bien sûr on peut
demander à ce que les négociations entre
après ça reste le jeu des négociations
là-dessus et c'est toute la difficulté
on le voit bien aujourd'hui c'est que
les réquisitions aujourd'hui ce sont que
des mesures de court terme on leur a pas
résolu le problème donc on va pas
commencer on va dire si les négociations
arrivent et que avant que les stocks on
va dire entre guillemets
soient épuisé et bien la faire dans
l'ordre si par contre on voit on utilise
des stocks et que ça suffit pas avec les
négociations n'ont pas avancées là ça
risque d'être plus rude pour l'économie
un mot justement j'anique alimy sur la
portée politique alors il y a un son un
sondage BFM et Lab qui est sorti il y a
très peu de temps là qui dit parce que
évidemment il y a la bataille de
l'opinion a gagné j'imagine puisque
c'est ça l'impact politique de ce qui se
passe 42% donc des Français approuvent
40% sont contre donc on voit que c'est
très divisé le l'opinion en français en
revanche vous avez 8 Français sur dix
qui trouve que l'exécutif n'a pas
vraiment joué son rôle bah oui on est
dans un pays qu'on le veuille ou non qui
est très colbertiste en même temps c'est
ce que disait Michel Ruiz sont des
entreprises ce sont des entreprises
privées oui tout à fait mais enfin on
reste quand même dans un dans un pays on
n'est pas les États-Unis on n'est pas la
Grande-Bretagne on est dans un pays où
l'État a toujours joué son rôle vous
parliez tout à l'heure du Grenelle qui a
eu lieu après 1968 on peut remonter à 36
avec Matignon on sait que l'État au-delà
des entreprises publiques qui deviennent
de plus en plus rares même si EDF est
prête à être nationalisé on sait que
l'État a un rôle extrêmement important
on lui demande pas de nationalité enfin
on pardon certains
nationalisation effectivement des
entreprises mais il a un fort pouvoir un
site actif on le sait et sans aller
jusqu'à la réquisition des patrons on
sait que si Monsieur Macron ou Monsieur
le Maire ou madame borne enfin surtout
monsieur Macron on verra ce qui va dire
tout à l'heure prend son téléphone
et appelle les patrons des entreprises
qui sont en défaut qui pourrait être en
déplo pour négocier
cela cela aurait des conséquences et les
Français reconnaissent à l'état en tout
cas même demande à l'état et quand on
dit l'État c'est l'exécutif d'intervenir
et de jouer ce rôle on peut le regretter
on reste dans un état extrêmement
centralisateur Jacopin bonapartis tout
ce que vous voudrez et la Cinquième
République n'a pas entre guillemets
améliorer en tout cas n'a pas changé les
choses oui les pouvoirs publics ont tout
intérêt à intervenir en plus depuis la
rentrée Emmanuel Macron
Emmanuel Macron voulait donner dès le
départ en tout cas Bruno Le Maire veut
dire il faut maintenant que la France
attire des investisseurs étrangers qu'on
intervienne pas c'est la raison pour
laquelle il ne voulait pas mettre en
place est-ce que vous croyez que les
investisseurs étrangers risquent d'être
attirés si la France est bloquée est-ce
que le syndrome comme disait certains de
la grève que j'ai appellerai pas
syndrome est-ce que ce n'est pas un
facteur beaucoup plus bloquant que un un
président de la République qui appelle
des patrons et des syndicats d'ailleurs
effectivement pour leur dire vous avez
intérêt à négocier dans le bien et dans
les intérêts partagés de tous le
gouvernement l'a joué petit bras au nom
peut-être d'une idéologie politique
extrêmement libérale au nom peut-être
d'un manque d'organisation et d'un
manque de remontée d'informations que ce
soit les préfets ou que ce soit certains
ministres l'avenir le dira en tout cas
il est temps que peut-être que Vulcain
redevienne Jupiter parce que Vulcain à
la fin n'a pas donné de résultat pour le
moment alors qui redevienne un Jupiter
mais un Jupiter efficace
bactéries justement qu'est-ce que vous
attendez est-ce qu'il va faire une
annonce ce soir Emmanuel Macron
éventuellement vous attendiez une
annonce on attend d'un gouvernement
qu'il gouverne aujourd'hui on a
l'impression de ne pas être gouverné
effectivement si on laisse comme disait
le Général de Gaulle là je suis en lit
dirigé ça ne marchera pas donc
aujourd'hui le marché ne s'auto régulera
pas effectivement il faut le blocage du
pays où c'est le fait bien sûr en fait
c'est le libéralisme sauvage c'est le
fait qu'il y ait effectivement pas de
capitaine à la barre c'est que on ne
puisse pas donner de direction c'est
qu'on laisse une minorité paralysée tout
un pays sans donner la direction qu'il
faut donc aujourd'hui effectivement il
faut que le gouvernement reprenne les
choses en main qu'il y ait une fin
vraiment des blocages
reprises en main pour vous ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire réquisition ça veut
dire on remet au travail
la direction cède aux 10% de demandes ce
n'est pas par la CGT ce n'est pas cédé
que d'entendre ce qui est véridique et
ce qui est vrai effectivement il n'y a
pas de partage des efforts de la part
des dirigeants de de entreprises et des
énergéticiens il faut qu'il soit mieux
contribution donc effectivement je pense
que le fond est bon par contre la forme
est à jeté parce que l'appareil Lisie
est inacceptable on va écouter Erics
tout de suite
ce gouvernement est rattrapé par par
l'épreuve que subissent les Français il
n'a pas anticipé la réquisition j'ai
interrogé personnellement hier j'ai
demandé à l'Assemblée nationale les
réquisitions mais une crise comme ça
elle s'anticipe elle se gèrent elle se
gère au début dans les premiers jours on
peut régler cette solution maintenant ça
a pris l'ampleur qui est énorme et des
millions de Français voient leur liberté
de travailler privé et puis on a vu
c'est aussi c'est le défaut de ce qui
nous gouverne aujourd'hui le manque
d'anticipation on ne réagit qu'après les
événements le manque de courage aussi
Thomas Porquet a sorti de crise
totale et Alexandre accède
revendications des salariés ce que je
crois que les salariés de Total
aujourd'hui et de l'action il se battent
pas que pour eux ils se battent pour
l'ensemble des salariés de ce pays pour
avoir des salaires digne vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure du SMIC le gouvernement
peut revaloriser par exemple le SMIC ce
qui n'a pas voulu à l'Assemblée et
l'extrême
de la crise et vous avez dit une
minorité dans votre sondage il y a
quasiment plus de 40% des Françaises des
Français qui aujourd'hui soutiennent le
soutiennent le mouvement parce que oui
il y a un problème de pouvoir d'achat
dans ce pays et quand vous avez un
patron qui s'augmente de 50 % et je le
redis parce que à un an c'est 312000 le
PDG de Total c'est un an 312 année 2000
et on a des gens qui contrairement à ce
qui est digne n'arrive pas à remplir
leur frigo la fin du mois donc il faut
augmenter les salaires et partager les
richesses dans ce pays pour l'instant
vous êtes tout de même 40 % des Français
qui sont contre cette justement ces
grèves bien sûr mais vous avez son
importance qui sont pour on est vraiment
en moitié-moitié là
je vous en prie il peut avoir un
mécontentement social qui n'est aussi de
ses 40 et quelques pourcents qui sont
opposés au blocage
des raffineries donc c'est pas parce
qu'il y a 40% ou pardonnez-moi à 42 ou
c'est 40% 40% au four enfin 40 % qui
sont contre ce mouvement mais vraiment
moi qui ne sont pas prêts eux à
descendre à descendre dans la rue à
manifester leur colère c'est 40% sont
certainement pas parmi les classes les
plus aisées de la population cela dit je
le répète ce serait plutôt un mouvement
de gilet jaune donc parce que ceux qui
sont pénalisés aujourd'hui sont
justement font partie d'une classe qui
n'est pas privilégiée c'est ce que vous
voulez dire aussi c'est plutôt de leurs
concerné
ce sont plutôt les professions les
classes les groupes les plus modestes
eux aussi peuvent être très mécontents
mais je ne suis pas sûr que leur lait
contentement encore une fois se
traduisent politiquement en faveur de la
gauche ça pourrait être certainement pas
en faveur d'Emmanuel Macron mais plutôt
en faveur du rassemblement national
comme on voulait la gagner cette
bataille de qui est très présent
également pardon dans les classes
modestes et populaires vous savez après
22 jours de grève et malgré tout ce
qu'on a entendu sur les plateaux on a
parlé de preneur d'otages et même
entendu des gens les qualifiés
d'assassins parce qu'il bloquaient les
infirmiers d'aller au boulot on a quand
même quatre Français sur 10 qui sont
aujourd'hui d'accord et ces mouvements
et puis je partais ce qui a été dit
c'est pas une question de céder à
revendications c'est une question
d'équité de justice sociale encore une
fois on a des groupes qui font de
l'argent et on a des salariés qui
demandent une revalorisation salariale
c'est pas une question de dire il faut
céder à ces revendications qui sont
totalement folles c'est une question de
partager les richesses parce que demain
les actions de total ils auront plus 1 €
en poche si on a plus de salariés qui
produisent la richesse qui sont sur le
terrain qui travaille en 3,8 qui respire
un air pollué toute la journée Michel
Rui quelle sortie de crise possible
je suis devant un constat c'est que
aujourd'hui la situation fait lever les
Français vis-à-vis d'autres Français
c'est ça montre la société qui est quand
même difficile et les difficultés la le
va être crise bien sûr ça veut dire ça
nécessite pas la satisfaction des deux
parties c'est notamment d'une part les
salariés qui bénéficient d'une
revalorisation de leur salaire ça
permettrait éventuellement à supposer
que ce soit que tout le monde soit
d'accord que ça facilite on va dire
l'activité économique par ailleurs parce
que et c'est ça qui moi me gêne c'est la
non prise de conscience qu'aujourd'hui
il y a de plus en plus de conflits des
vers les autres et on n'a pas de
solution le gouvernement ne me donne pas
l'impression de trouver la bonne
solution pour essayer de faire ça moi je
pense que ça n'est pas simple
bien sûr que ce n'est pas ça simplement
le fait de dire que et je rentre pas
dans le débat sur le la divulgation des
niveaux de salaire on tient pas compte
aussi des pénibilités et ainsi de suite
donc la communication totale
des pauvres entre guillemets donc c'est
là aussi
ont été comptés
qui travaillent sur les raffineries donc
c'est moi qui me gêne c'est ce de fait
pour qu'on arrive à jouer à jouer
là-dessus je pense que il faudrait
arriver à meilleur dialogue ça passe par
le haut ça passe par le bas faut que
tout le monde ait conscience que tout
passera par un dialogue d'aller vers
l'autre
responsabilisation c'est un peu le
d'accord avec ce qui vient d'être dit
mais on voit bien qu'effectivement
depuis des années et pour ne prendre que
le court terme on a bien vu que la
France était effectivement braqué au
moins au moins entre deux groupes depuis
depuis 2017 c'était même avant avec une
nuit debout et la loi khomri de François
Hollande on va pas refaire l'histoire
mais justement et c'est là encore une
fois que je veux reparler du
gouvernement qui en plus avait cette
philosophie politique au début en 2017
c'est très compliqué de faire parler les
deux France pour pour aller vite même si
on a certainement plus parle plutôt d'un
archipel français comme dirait Jérôme
Fourquet il faut une tierce personne un
tiers un tiers parti j'allais dire non
c'est mal dit c'est en ce sens que le
gouvernement alors je ne sais pas à quel
niveau pourrait jouer ce rôle de
médiateur d'autant plus que ça fait
partie de la philosophie politique
d'Emmanuel Macron qui sera attaché à la
seconde gauche de de Monsieur Rocard qui
lui aussi prenait la négociation entre
deux ou trois parties avec ce média
négociation au niveau national c'est ça
que vous voulez dire Janique parce que
évidemment les patrons total
idée c'est compliqué on a dépassé le
stade de la branche est-ce qu'ils font
en rester à la branche énergéticienne je
sais pas comment on dit chimie peut-être
là j'avoue que je j'avoue que je n'ai
pas cette ingénierie sociale et
politique en tête mais c'est peut-être
effectivement on est quand même à un
moment extrêmement particulier de
l'histoire de la France et de l'histoire
du monde peut-être faut-il effectivement
une sorte de Grenelle ou de Matignon ou
le tas l'état j'aurais le rôle
d'intermédiaire sinon c'est la chanlie à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a pas de
majorité absolue c'est lâché en lit
peut-être en tout cas des revendications
dans la rue et on se demande si un
pilote dans l'avion sur quoi tout ça
peut déboucher
30 secondes pour terminer
ce qu'il nous faut c'est un vrai partage
des efforts il faut envoyer ce signal
fort aujourd'hui parce que quand encore
une fois les Français se prive de tout
que ce soit de manière financière ou
dans leur mode de vie et qu'en parallèle
on voit des personnes qui font des
supers prophéties sans aucun partage
par exemple pour vous ils sont couverts
par le gouvernement ça donne le résultat
qu'on a aujourd'hui donc aujourd'hui il
nous faut vraiment une répartition plus
juste des efforts des profits et une
répartition aussi plus juste des revenus
du travail et du capital merci beaucoup
les arts of bactéries merci Janick
Halimi Merci à VOUS Michel ruimi merci
Thomas forte merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivis et vous restez avec nous
sur France 24
[Musique]